you guys became very good friends on
that show and you're you're still closed
is that right you and Nick Offerman we
are close you know um
we're very close I mean we're but I
there's something that's happened that's
sort of I feel like tearing us apart
which is sad for a long time Nick Adam
and I would had this pact that if we had
a really exceptional poop we would take
a picture of it and send it to one
another you know and and recently maybe
a later episode this is something that's
really yeah yeah I know this is the
three of you would do this as a way to
bond like a share experience just right
just right yes you would you look at a
poop and think that's an offer Minh I'm
sending that to Nick
I think it started when I miraculously
pooped in an N shape one time and then I
sent it and I sent it to Nick and I said
hey it was on Nick's birthday
I said you guys have the same birthday
[Applause]
and so but but recently oh no my wife
and I we got this special toilet is that
one of those Japanese ones we're getting
those they the lid opens automatic yeah
super Jetsons they washes your be whole
and does the whole deal it's amazing and
but it flushes your poop for you so like
I might get up I'll go yeah that's
enough I'm like
so there's Toro toilet toro toilets the
only toilet to wash your behold I don't
know if that's their slogan but it
should be you know what Chris you're a
big enough star now that you could get a
lot of great tires you could you could
probably be like a nor'easter guy or a
Porsche and you just sold your entire
soul to Toro - whoo Toro
[Applause]
toto
I love that Andy's looked into this
right now I know but now you can't send
it pictures anymore cuz the toilet cuz
the toilets alright alright alright
you